>> Gail Shirazi: Good afternoon.
I'm Gail Shirazi of the
Israel and Judaica section
at the Library of Congress.
Welcome to the Library,
and today's program,
"Shores Beyond Shores,"
with author Irene Butter,
and co-authors, John
Bidwell and Kris Holloway.
This event commemorates the 80th
anniversary of Kristallnacht,
the night of the broken glass,
November 9th to 10th, 1938,
a crucial event in the
run-up to the Holocaust.
And we have books.
Irene's books will be for sale,
and she'll be signing
them after the event.
I want to thank you, Mary
Bisby-Beck [assumed spelling].
I want to thank Walter --
Professor Walter Reich,
Michel Wingfield
[assumed spellings],
and the special events office,
and our two co-authors also.
And I would like to
acknowledge, if they're here,
some of the distinguished
guests.
Is Debbie Dingell,
Congresswoman Dingell here?
Congressman Joe Kennedy
and Jim McGovern --
they said they would stop by if
nothing else pulled them away,
and since it is the
new Congress,
they may have been
pulled away [laughter].
We have representatives for
the Embassy of the Netherlands.
Thank you for coming.
Sam Adams, the former mayor
of Portland, Oregon right
over there, and Anthony
Fowler, the deputy chair
of the Federal Holocaust
Remembrance Committee,
right back there.
A crucial way to honor the
memory of those who perished
in the Holocaust, and ensure
they are not forgotten,
is to preserve historical
documents and artifacts.
To that end, the Library
of Congress offers rich
resources to the public.
LC has more than 158
million items, including more
than 36 million books --
-- and printed material
in 460 languages.
Across the Library's
vast holdings,
there are Holocaust-related
material
in many languages and formats.
Written resources can
include Ytzkor books,
which are memorial
volumes, personal memoirs,
eyewitnesses' accounts,
and scholarly works.
They're all found
throughout the Library.
Moving image section
has newsreels and films,
such as these two
donated by Irene today.
Genealogy resources are
in our local history
and genealogy reading room,
photographs in our prints
and photographs division,
maps in our geography
and map division, sound
recordings and sheet music
in our music division.
Periodicals and government
documents in our serials
and government publications
division, oral histories
from soldiers who liberated
the concentration camps
in our veterans'
history project.
We have digital resources
and many, many others.
There are experts in
each of these divisions
to assist the public, so
please get a reader's card
and use our extraordinary
collections.
Now, I would like to ask
survivors, hidden children,
and children and
grandchildren of the Holocaust
to rise and be recognized.
Thank you.
It impacts many generations,
not just the generation
that was in the Holocaust.
Our greatest resources are our
survivors and their witnesses.
Their stories must be
recorded and passed on.
Irene, Kris, and John
are doing just that.
It's a privilege to
have them here today.
And now, a bit about Irene.
Professor Butter holds a B.A.
from Queens College in New York.
She was one of the first
women to receive a Ph.D.
in economics from Duke.
She is professor emeritus of
health management and policy
of the University of Michigan
School of Public Health.
She is founder of the
Raoul Wallenberg --
and lecture series at the
University of Michigan,
and cofounder of Zeitouna,
an Arab-Jewish women's
dialogue group.
Now, our presentation,
and afterwards,
we'll have a questions
and answer period.
Thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg
Butter: Good afternoon.
Do you hear me?
Thank you all so much for
coming, and thank you, Gail,
for the opportunity to
present our book at the Library
of Congress, "Shores Beyond
Shores, From Holocaust to Hope,"
with my wonderful co-authors,
John Bidwell and Kris Holloway,
who -- together, we worked on
this book for a long, long time.
And I'm so appreciative that
our presentation is linked
to the Library of
Congress's commemoration
of the 80th anniversary
of Kristallnacht,
which is a crucial event that
should never be forgotten.
So when we started writing
this book, our primary aim was
to describe the experiences of
a child during the Holocaust,
and to revive the voice of
the child as she saw things,
heard things, and felt things
that were going on around her.
The aim was that this
should never be forgotten,
but unfortunately,
today, we see echoes
of actions during the
Holocaust all around the world,
and even in our own country.
So in a way, the
book is a bridge
from the past to the present.
Now, what we'll do today is,
we're going to read
from the book.
First Kris Bidwell -- Kris
Holloway will read a section
that takes place in Amsterdam
about the loss of freedoms
for the Jews, and then I will
follow, reading a section
of an event in Westerbork, which
was the first concentration camp
that my family and
I were sent to.
And then, John will read
a passage of a happening
in Bergen-Belsen, which was
the second concentration camp
that my family and
myself experienced.
And after our readings,
we will have a closing.
We'll have a session
of kind of wrapping up,
and that will be talking
about some themes of the book,
and also linkages from
the past to the present,
and some of what we're
experiencing today.
>> Kris Holloway: Great.
Hello, everyone.
Can you hear me?
Is this on?
Great. So when we set out to
write this story with Irene,
a lot of people have asked
about what was that like,
having two co-authors working
with a Holocaust survivor
to write the book, and how
in the world did
you get to know her?
And so, I wanted to say
that Irene was my
graduate school advisor
at the University of Michigan.
I did not know that she
was a Holocaust survivor.
She was my advisor, but I
got pregnant really fast.
I thought it would
take a couple years.
I got pregnant with my first
child my first semester
in grad school, and
I didn't know
if I could actually pull it off.
The University of
Michigan is a hard school.
I know GW is too, got some
students here [laughter].
And so, I really thought that
I might not make it through,
and Irene supported me.
She said, "You're studying
maternal and child health.
Stay [laughter].
I will help you.
I'll take care of Aiden [assumed
spelling] during these meetings"
-- my little boy.
And really, without her
support, I don't know
if I would've made
it through that time.
She gave me such support,
and obviously John as well.
And then, she was the
second person after John
to hold our second son
at his birth at our home
in Ann Arbor 21 years ago.
So we have stayed really
close friends, and it has been
such a privilege to
have this time to work
with her on the memoir.
I was about five years in
the writing, and just came
out this past January.
So one of my -- because I
feel like I connect with Irene
through our children, and she
has such spark and such love
for children, one
of my favorite parts
of writing the book was really
those early years of Irene's.
And so, Irene was born
in 1930 in Berlin.
Her family fled, and they
unfortunately did not flee
far enough.
Her father was able to
get a job in Amsterdam
with the American
Express company,
and thought that was far
enough away from the Nazis,
which we know now, it wasn't.
And so, the scene that I
want to read to you is set --
they moved to Amsterdam in 1938.
This is the summer of 1941.
So Irene has been
there for three years.
She's 11 years old, and it's
a scene with her best friend,
Vera, her brother, Werner --
her older brother, Werner,
whose son, John, is here with us
as well, and a boy named Rudy,
who Irene had her
first crush on.
And Irene, in the
book, is called Rini,
which was her nickname.
"With summer's start,
the sun strengthened,
stretching out its warm light
farther into the evening.
It was June, 1941,
and Vera, Werner,
and I stayed outside
as long as possible.
Along the nearby canal,
we gathered on our bikes
to ride along the water's edge.
My metal horse and
Vera's were fast friends,
as they flew along
at a full gallop.
We grasped the looping
handlebars,
and steered the big
wheels ahead.
Go. At night, the brick
paths along the canals were
smooth trails.
We barely felt the jiggling
space between the bricks
as our fat tires
traveled over them.
The two young families were
at home, and people roamed --
the young families were at home,
and people roamed
leisurely in twos.
We sped along, heady with
the early night smells
of pollen and full leaves.
Werner was strongest, and could
fly up the bridges and back
down long before we could,
up, and down, and around.
My ears jumped between the
sounds of birds setting
in for the night, bugs
waking up, water lapping
at the canal walls, a
far-off barrel organ,
and our chains' rhythmic
straining against gears.
We picked up Rudy from his home.
He was almost as fast as
Werner, and twice as graceful.
His long legs and arms
moved like a dancer's.
We took over a street, and rode
side by side, all four of us.
Evening lights slowly
turned on here and there,
reflections shining up from
the water in shimmering light.
We came upon a small park
in the middle of a square
with winding brick paths around
small shrubs and statues.
Rudy pedaled up, wound
between the blackened shrubs,
and disappeared.
Werner came to a halt at the
entrance, and held up his hand
for Vera and me to stop.
We backpedaled on the brakes,
both of us sliding into the back
of his bike with a crack.
Tacked up on a tree was a sign,
[foreign language],
Jews forbidden.
In the lower-right corner
was an official police seal.
'Rudy, come back!'
Werner yelled, fear
edging into his voice.
'Rudy!' I called.
I looked at the deserted
streets, and whispered
to the night to let him
come back before anyone saw.
He flew back around the corner
just then, almost knocking
into us, his eyes wide,
and filled with light.
Werner pointed to the sign.
Rudy stopped smiling.
All of our bikes,
like eager steeds,
strained to go on,
but we turned back.
Our horses had turned
into just bicycles."
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg Butter:
So I am reading a conversation
between my brother, Werner,
two years older than I was
at that time, and he had a job
in Camp Westerbork
as a messenger.
And he knew a lot
more than I did
about what was going
on in the camp.
"Werner had been looking for my
friend Rudy, a boy from my class
that I had a crush on.
He and his family had been
deported before our turn came,
and I was hoping to find
him again in Westerbork.
Westerbork was a camp
that was divided in half
by a railway track, and
every Saturday afternoon,
the long cattle car
train arrived.
It stood there all of
Saturday, all of Sunday,
and all of Monday,
and it was this long,
long car with empty
-- empty car --
empty railroad car,
empty and hungry.
No matter where I went during
those days, whether I went
to dinner, whether I went to
see friends in other barracks,
or I went to hang up
laundry on the laundry lines,
I couldn't avoid
this ominous train.
Now, that evening, at dinner,
Werner was less talkative
than usual about what
he had been hearing,
what was going on in the camp.
His excitement about
his job had faded,
and his lips were tightened.
And he was biting his nails.
'What is it?'
I asked him, as we sat on
the steps of our barracks.
'Nothing,' he replied.
'Leave me alone.
Don't hassle me about
your Rudy.'
'He's not my Rudy,' I said.
Werner didn't make a
comeback, nor did he tease me
about hassling him as
much as I usually did.
'Rini,' he said,
picking at his cuticles,
'you know this is a
transit camp, right?
It is a camp that sends
people to other places.'
'Yeah. Tell me something
new,' I said.
'You know,' he said, 'I have
been looking for Rudy high
and low, as you have, but his
family boarded the train a few
weeks before we arrived here.
He's gone.
I found out yesterday.'
'Why didn't you tell
me immediately?'
I said. He paused.
Then he said, 'Because I
heard other things as well,
and I wanted to check them out
and make sure that they're true.
Rudy left for that
camp some time ago.
The camp he left
for is Auschwitz.
Auschwitz is worse
than this camp.'
So I said to him, 'How could
it be worse than this camp?
We've been taken
away from our home.
Who knows who has all the
stuff that we left behind?
We're bored here, and
doing stupid work.
All the food we brought
with us is gone,
and the camp only has
gross soup and stale bread.
And we have to use
bathrooms without doors.'
I felt panic rising
in my throat.
'Rini, you don't
understand,' he said.
'I understand.
I understand that you
didn't tell me about Rudy
when you found out
that he had left.'
'They don't just bore
you, or even starve you
at Auschwitz,' said Werner.
'They kill you.
I had to hear it a lot of
times before I believed it.
They kill people at
camps like Auschwitz.
They kill Jews like
us, and like Rudy.'
His voice rose, and he
choked on his last words."
>> John Bidwell: The family
had been in Westerbork
for about 10 months before
they were finally deported
to Bergen-Belsen, and this
scene is late spring 1944.
They've been in Bergen-Belsen
for about four months,
and there's been an influx
of prisoners at that time.
The Nazis were just beginning
to really lose the war,
and rather than liberate
prisoners,
they would be sending
them to other camps.
Many of them ended up
going to Bergen-Belsen.
Bergen-Belsen, at this
point, was swelling in size
with the number of prisoners,
and there were harsher
conditions.
It was more cramped,
and there was less food.
And that's where we
pick up at this scene.
"At first, hunger was a pesky
neighbor, sometimes noisy
at night, interrupting sleep.
Then, it was a nagging
visitor who came rapping
on the door more and more.
Finally, it had the keys.
Hunger marched in, and
hunger settled down.
As the spring months dragged
on, and the cold raced
across the camp through every
crevice, under every blanket,
hunger went from a
distant stranger,
to an annoying acquaintance,
to a constant companion.
There was no place to
escape, no room to retire to.
It became an ever-present
day-after-day rumbling.
As mothers, fathers, and
relatives started returning
from work in the
late afternoons,
I left my job watching kids
to get our daily rations.
I waited in the long line with
other kids and some adults.
With food becoming
increasingly scarce,
adults started pushing kids
out of the way to get ahead.
I watched carefully.
It always paid to be
attentive when it came to food.
If needed, I would be more
commanding, and ask the servers
for more vegetables,
and I always measured the
size of the hunk of bread.
Again, I would protest
if needed.
I wasn't loud, but I was quick.
Then I returned to our
bunks, and I waited.
I put my -- I sat on my bunk,
arms around our pail of food,
pulling what warmth I could,
and inhaling the smell.
Hunger sat beside me, whispering
in my ear, 'Eat it all.
It would be so easy.'
It wasn't much, and for the
first time in almost a year,
I would be able to sleep
with a full stomach.
I slid my finger around the
inside edge of the pail,
feeling the moisture
build to drops.
When nobody was looking, I put
a shaking finger to my tongue.
My senses bounced between
the all-absorbing taste,
and listening for my family's
approaching footfalls,
my mother's delicate gait and
my father's longer shuffle.
The barracks darkened
with the evening.
The food cooled.
Every minutes, I
collected drops of soup,
telling myself it
would've evaporated anyhow.
I couldn't wait anymore.
With careful measure,
I took my portion
of food, and I devoured it.
But instead of feeling better,
I found myself more ravenous.
I dipped my spoon with my
shaking hand into the pail,
and a few more times,
and I picked off
and ate the uneven bread ends.
As the food hit my lips,
my body wanted to slurp
down every last drop, and
chew down every last crumb.
I kept thinking I
heard my family,
only to realize I was wrong.
Then there was no mistake.
I was terrified that
they would say something
about the portions, or read my
guilt, but I was also relieved
that I was free of
further temptation.
They said nothing.
Poppy sat.
My father took off
his worn-out shoes,
lay down, and closed his eyes.
I looked over at my
mother, who stayed upright,
but leaned her head against
the frame of the bunk.
'Okay, Rini, do you have
anything hearty for us?'
My father asked after
a few minutes.
In the past, he might've added
something like he was starving.
'Of course,' I said,
and took the brown pot
from under my blanket.
'Have you seen your brother?'
My mother asked.
I shook my head.
She took a deep breath,
looking around.
Poppy, my father,
moved to her side,
resting his hand
on her bony leg.
They both looked
at me and nodded.
They refused to eat until I did.
'I -- I already had
mine,' I said.
'Do you need more?'
Poppy asked.
'No, I'm fine.'
'Take more, Rini,'
my mother said.
'I'm not hungry.
I'm fine. My belly doesn't
feel well today,' I lied,
and then seeing their
concern, added, 'but it's not
that bad -- my belly, I mean.'
And so they passed the
brown pot and the bread,
saving more than
Werner's share for him."
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg Butter:
Well, now to some themes
and closing of our presentation.
I want to first talk
about something positive,
and that refers to the
opportunities we had
when we immigrated to the
United States in 1945 and 1946.
My brother -- my mother, my
brother, and I were separated,
and so we -- I came first.
I was -- I spent one year in
a refugee camp in Algiers,
in Phillipville, and I was
not allowed to be reunited
with my mother and brother,
who were in Switzerland.
They had been hospitalized
immediately
when we arrived there,
after a prisoner exchange
that took place between
people from Bergen-Belsen
who had passports of South
and Central American countries
and German citizens who were
in internment camps
in the United States.
So when we arrived here as
a family, we were penniless,
because the Nazis had taken
everything away that we had.
We were homeless, naturally.
We didn't have a home,
and we were stateless.
And I think this is a feature
that is not often mentioned,
and not well understood.
But in 1935, Hitler deprived
all German Jews of citizenship,
and that's what statelessness
means, that it is a person
who doesn't have
citizenship in any country,
and therefore has no right to
be admitted to any country.
So on the other hand,
every country can refuse
to admit people who
are stateless.
And I recently read that
there are 20 million stateless
refugees in the world today.
What's going to happen to them?
Despite the fact -- well, I
would just say that when I came
to America, one of the
first actions I took is
to apply for citizenship.
And at that time,
it took five years.
First you had to apply for first
papers, and two years later,
you applied for second papers.
Then, usually, the fifth year,
you would get citizenship,
and I don't remember any
immigrants that I knew
who were denied citizenship
in this country.
So from 1935 to 1950,
I was stateless,
and I have great sympathy
for all those 20 million
stateless people in this world.
We don't know what's
going to happen to them.
Now, we arrived here penniless.
My mother had never
worked before.
My brother and I had
not had any education
for three and a half years.
I was very eager to go to
school, finished high school
in two and a half years, and
then went to a city college
in New York City which
was tuition-free.
It was an excellent eduction
that I received there,
and who can imagine sending
kids to college these days
that are free of tuition?
And I'm forever grateful
for that.
From -- after my graduation
from Queens College,
I attended Duke University with
scholarships and assistantships,
and that's how I received
my Ph.D. in economics.
The job market then
was favorable.
Even my mother, who had
never worked before,
was able to find a --
not skilled jobs,
but unskilled jobs.
And so, the three of us
worked to pay the bills,
and that was possible
in those days.
I wish this were possible
for immigrants coming
to our country today.
Unfortunately, we see the echoes
of actions taken
during the Holocaust
in the -- at the present time.
We see it all over the world,
and we also see it
in our own country.
Ethnic cleansing,
white supremacy,
deportation of certain groups,
dehumanization, the deprivation
of basic human rights --
all of that, we see today.
It's different groups now,
because we saw a horrendous
anti-Semitic incident recently
in Pittsburgh, a murderous
incident at a synagogue.
But Jews don't compose
the only group
that is targeted at
the present time.
People from Africa,
African-Americans, Muslims,
people from Latin America -- all
are mistreated in various ways,
and it is very painful to see
that our democratic values --
some of them, anyway --
appear to be eroding.
So my wish for the
future would be
that all the targeted
groups would come together,
form an alliance, and revive
the basic traditions --
American traditions and values,
such as liberty, freedom,
and equal opportunity for all.
And I'd like to quote one
of my favorite heroes,
Martin Luther King, who
said, "The arc of moral --
the arc of the moral
universe is long,
but it bends towards justice."
And it is my belief that justice
is everybody's responsibility.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Gail Shirazi: Have some time
from questions and answers.
Is there anyone that
has a question?
Yes?
>> Microphone -- come up here?
>> Gail Shirazi: No, he's
coming with the microphone.
>> Thank you.
Irene, I know in my
family, we had people
who immigrated earlier, and
helped bring other people in.
Did you -- you know, from
Algeria, did you have relatives
in Queens, or in New York
or whatever that helped you?
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg
Butter: Yes, that's correct.
At that time, one
needed affidavits.
You couldn't get a visa
without affidavits,
and those were statements -- we
had family that they promised
that they would take care of you
if you were not self-sufficient.
They had to prove that
they had a bank account,
and that they had savings.
They would be able to do
that, and so our family here
in the United States -- in New
York provided these affidavits.
It still took a long time.
It took one year before --
almost one year before I was
able to get a visa in Algiers,
and it took even longer
for my mother and brother,
who were still in Switzerland.
And I might just mention
that the relatives we had had
only come to America recently.
You know, they were only
a few years ahead of us,
maybe four years, and they
had also been deprived
of all their possessions.
So for them, it was difficult to
make a living, but they managed.
But they didn't have
a whole lot to spare.
Nevertheless, they took us
in with great generosity.
>> Thank you.
>> I want to thank you for
a wonderful presentation.
I would like to ask whether in
reflecting on your experience,
you have any views about
the periodic madness
that seems to sweep humankind.
There have been genocides
of many sorts in many places
as long as I've been observing,
and whether you have any
thoughts about humankind moving
to avoid these forms of
genocides and madness.
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg Butter:
Well, that is a big question.
You know, we have
used the phrase
"never again" for
50, 60 years now.
It has been repeated
numerous times,
but saying it is not
going to make it happen.
And so, there needs
to be more action,
action of interrupting hatred,
of people who are targeted
by hatred to come
together and fight
for what is legal
and what is just.
And I think we all
have a responsibility
to protect each other, and
not see another group being
discriminated against,
or being persecuted,
or being put in tent camps.
We all need to be active,
and I think too often we think
the problems are so large,
and each individual is so small
that we can't do anything.
But that is not true.
Every little step really helps,
and we can form alliances.
And I wish that people in our
Congress would object more
to the things that are not
just, and that do not correspond
to American traditions,
and that are illegal.
There's too much silence.
>> Gail Shirazi:
Another question?
Yes?
>> Thank you.
I am immigrated twice, so I
know where you're coming from.
I escaped from Egypt, then I
left France and came to America.
And I salute the flag every
day, which is in my living room.
>> Gail Shirazi:
And your question?
>> And my question is,
what is the seminal event
that propelled you
to write the book?
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg
Butter: Well,
thank you for that question.
There are several, but I will
mention that, first of all,
there were four decades
of silence.
And my family and myself never
talked about the Holocaust,
but then there was an awakening.
And one person responsible for
the awakening is Elie Wiesel,
who talked a lot to
Holocaust survivors,
and assigned the
responsibility to witness,
to provide testimony,
and to tell the stories.
And I have a quote in my book I
heard him say once to survivors.
"If you were in the camps,
if you smelled the air,
if you heard the
silence of the dead,
then you must be a witness.
You must provide
testimony, for if you don't,
the dead will die twice."
And that made a very
deep impression on me,
and I started talking.
Another incident was, my
daughter, when she was
in middle school -- she took
a course in public speaking,
and at the end of the course,
she had to do a one-hour
speech to the class.
And she chose the following
topic, "Anti-Semitism,
Hitler's Conquest of Europe,
and the Concentration Camps."
And she came home,
and she said, "Mom,
will you be my visual aid?"
[Laughter] And even though
I was petrified to do that,
because I had been
silent for four decades,
I couldn't turn her down.
So I have been speaking
in schools for more
than 35 years now, and
it's enriched my life,
because whenever I talk in
a school, I ask the teachers
to have the students send
something to me afterward --
a question, a thought, how
it changed their thinking,
or just a picture,
whatever it is.
I have an enormous
archive of gifts,
of really beautiful gifts,
and I know that someday I
won't be able to go to schools
and speak to them, speak
to the students anymore.
So that is also a reason
for writing the book.
At least, then, the
book will be available.
>> Gail Shirazi: Yes?
>> Dr. Butter, thank you so
much for being here today,
and thank you for your words.
My name is Nathan, and
I'm a college student here
in the Washington, D.C. area.
For several years -- for several
years -- for several years,
since I was in elementary
school,
I've been deeply interested
in learning about memories
and experiences from
the Holocaust.
So it has been essentially
a lifelong interest for me.
Professionally, I'm seriously
considering working in a --
working in Holocaust
education, and my question is,
what do you think is
particularly important
for young people such as myself
to know and to understand?
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg
Butter: Very good question.
You know, I tell students
that during the Holocaust,
there were the perpetrators,
and then there were the victims.
But what about the bystanders?
So many people may not
have agreed with Nazism,
and with whatever happened to
the Jews, but what did they do?
Would Hitler have been
able to be so successful,
and kill six million Jews
and six million other people,
if people hadn't been passive,
and hadn't objected, opposed,
interrupted, demonstrated,
and all those things?
I know there were
rules against it.
I know there was risk in
objecting the Nazi regime,
but still, we have to be active.
We have to be vigilant, and so,
one of the documentaries I
think that's here is called
"Never A Bystander."
And that is the concept
I try to submit --
transmit to the students.
>> I'm Tony Fowler with the
U.S. Department of Education.
I'm so grateful to
be here today.
I wanted to ask you, from
your experience with --
in academia, but also -- you
just spoke about speaking
to students across the country.
What hope do you draw
from your experiences
with younger generations today?
Some of us see reports all the
time coming across our desk,
and it doesn't look
like there's any hope.
But I'd love to hear your
perspective on the hope
that you see in the upcoming
generations in the United States
and elsewhere, where
you have had experience.
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg Butter:
Thank you for that question.
Well, that's what
I'm talking about.
The letters and the
poems, the verses
and the drawings I receive
from students are amazing,
and actually, I wanted to write
a book that would include all
of these beautiful gifts,
because they are so hopeful.
I mean, students will tell
me, "It is the responsibility
of my generation to eliminate
genocide from this planet."
Or they will say, "I'm no
longer going to be a bystander.
I want to help poor people,
and I want to interrupt
bullying on the playground."
Now, that's another one
where often students watch
another child being bullied,
and I recommend that they don't
do that, that they intervene.
They could be an ally to the
child that's being bullied.
They can confront the bullier.
They can ask for help, and
if they're the first one,
then maybe there'd
be a following,
and many people will
object to the bullying.
And there's so many letters I
have that are so touching, of --
some students will say,
"You've changed my life.
You've changed my
thinking about the world.
You've changed who
I am, who I am going
to be, who I want to be."
So the favorite student
population
that I have are middle
school kids,
because they're not
so well-informed.
They are uninhibited
[laughter], and they come
up with beautiful statements.
Now, I don't know
what I would find
if I could see the same
students 10 years from now,
but I hope that I have
had an impact on them.
And they're very compassionate,
and very understanding,
and I think, in a way, ready --
ready to hear about that part
of history from someone
who experienced it.
>> Gail Shirazi:
Another question?
>> Hi, I'm Lorrie Gilbert
[assumed spelling],
and the daughter of a survivor.
And my mom was friends and
camp companions with Irene.
Irene, I've always wondered
how HIAS came into the role
when you were immigrating to
the U.S., H-I-A-S, and what role
that played, and how the group
helped you, and helped my mom
and her family when
they came to the U.S.
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg
Butter: Well, I don't have
such a clear memory, but I know
that HIAS was the organization,
sort of the middle
person between the people
who were sponsoring
immigrants and the immigrants,
or the displaced
persons where they were.
And I think they played a role
in having my relatives
provide the affidavit,
and then following up
so we could get visas.
It took a long time, but I
think that they monitored this,
and also promoted
it at every step.
And I don't know if it
would've been possible
without an organization
like HIAS.
>> Gail Shirazi:
Another question?
I've got one.
To the co-authors, I'd like
to know how much you knew
about the Holocaust
before you met Irene.
Is it something you've studied?
Was it on your radar at all?
>> John Bidwell: There have
been a few incidents in my life
where I've been truly
shocked, in terms of knowledge.
And I was in eighth grade when
the Holocaust TV series came on,
and we did a section on
it in social studies.
And I was just emotionally
floored,
because I just couldn't imagine
that anybody would do this
to other people, much less
in such a methodical way.
So it's something that I've been
very aware of, and very moved
about since eighth grade.
So, yeah, that's my
background on this.
>> Kris Holloway: I was
aware more from a health
and human rights standpoint,
but not the details.
So I think it was
getting into the details,
and understanding the
system, and how many people,
and its place in
history, and the political
and social atmosphere of the
time that I learned a lot about.
>> John Bidwell: The only
other thing I would add is
that I've had quite a few
family serve in the military.
I had two uncles.
One was in Normandy, and
the other was in Okinawa.
And both were deeply
influenced by their time
in the Pacific theater
and in Europe.
And when they came back,
a big topic in my family
was the hardship of war,
how it was a dedication,
something you really --
it was important to serve,
but at the same time,
there was a huge price
that needed to be paid.
And I -- that was something
that also made me very aware
and very acutely
aware of the need
to remember what
happened during this --
especially the Second World War.
So getting to know Irene
has been a true honor,
and to help tell her story is
something that has been one
of the most meaningful and
moving things of my life.
>> Gail Shirazi:
Any other questions?
>> I have one last question.
My father --
>> Gail Shirazi: Wait
for the mike [laughter].
Just one second.
>> -- so my father, who
was a World War II veteran,
who's passed, was increasingly
infuriated by the deniers,
the people who have
the audacity to claim
that the Holocaust
didn't take place.
So my question is,
what do you do,
or how do you maintain
your composure when
and if you encounter
what I apparently see
as an increasing
number of these people
who choose to rewrite history?
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg Butter:
That's a good question, too.
I had an incident not long
ago, when I was speaking
at public library in Ann Arbor,
and a Holocaust denier
entered the room,
and was in the back row.
And he started talking --
all of this is nonsense,
and a few other sentences.
And then he said, "Even Elie
Wiesel admits there were no gas
chambers in Auschwitz."
So people were getting
pretty upset,
and I think the library staff
was about to call the police.
But, you know, I said to him
that -- I said, "You are a liar,
and you'd better
not repeat this."
And then he left [laughter].
>> Kris Holloway:
Call it like it was.
Got it. Call it like it is.
>> Gail Shirazi:
I have just one --
if there are no other questions,
I have just one more little one.
Could you speak about
your encounter --
could you please speak about
your encounter with Anne Frank?
I found that particularly
moving,
what happened afterwards.
Could you say a few
words about that?
>> Dr. Irene Hasenberg Butter:
Well, the Frank family had sort
of a very similar background.
They came from Frankfurt.
They immigrated to
The Netherlands.
The Franks and my family
lived in the same neighborhood
in Amsterdam, but Anne was
about two years older than I,
and we didn't go
to the same school.
And I didn't know her
well, but I had a friend
who was in Anne's class.
And she was a neighbor
and a friend,
and she often told me
stories about Anne.
And there were many
stories about her,
because she was naughty
[laughter].
And so, then our paths
crossed in Bergen-Belsen,
because as some of you probably
know, the family went to hiding.
They were betrayed,
sent to Auschwitz.
The mother did not survive.
The -- Anne and Margot
were sent to Bergen-Belsen
when the Russians
entered Poland,
and Auschwitz was closed up.
The father was the only one who
survived of the Frank family,
and so I was in the same
barrack in Bergen-Belsen
as another friend of Anne's.
And one night, she
went to the fence --
we were separated from the women
from Auschwitz by barbed wire,
and we weren't allowed
to go near there.
But it was dark, and she went.
And she heard some
people speak Dutch,
and so she inquired whether
Anne Frank was there.
And they said yes,
and they fetched her,
and brought her to the fence.
And Hanna Lee [assumed spelling]
said she was very thin,
and she said, "Can I
do anything for you?"
And she said, "If you
could get me some clothes,"
because Anne didn't
have any clothes.
She just had a gray
blanket wrapped around her.
And Hanna Lee said, "Yes,
I'll come back tomorrow,
same time, same place."
And then she came to the
barrack and told me about it,
and together, we gathered
a bundle of clothing,
because they had never taken
our clothes away from us.
Now, of course, after almost two
years in camps, they were rags,
but we had more than we needed
-- more rags than we needed.
So we made a bundle, and
so Hanna Lee and I went
to the fence the next evening.
And Anne came, and we threw
the bundle over the fence.
And another woman came, picked
it up, and ran off with it.
So that was the last --
then a few days after that,
my family was included
in a prisoner exchange,
so we left Bergen-Belsen.
And many years later, I met
with Hanna Lee in Jerusalem,
and she told me that she had
thrown over another bundle
over the fence, and that
time, Anne did get it.
But both Anne and her sister,
Margot, had typhus eventually,
and they died in the camp.
>> Gail Shirazi:
Any other questions?
Well, I want to thank
our panelists.
Irene, you're amazing, and
to come out with such hope,
and such determination --
you deserve a lot of credit.
And thank you for
helping her record
and document her
very special history.
>> John Bidwell: I'd just
like to add one last thing.
Before you clap, which
is well-deserved,
if you're interested in more,
you can go to irenebutter.com,
irenebutter.com, the website,
and there's a lot more
information there.
There's also teaching guides,
if any of you are teachers,
photographs and video.
Just wanted to add that.
Thank you.
>> Gail Shirazi: Is it all
downloadable and free access?
>> John Bidwell: It's all free,
but feel free to pay [laughter].
It's all --
>> Gail Shirazi: Well,
I want to thank you.
[ Applause ]